et pour en parler nous sommes avec
younes belle fait la économiste
spécialiste du monde arabe réunionnaise
belle fait là bon soir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vient entendre
bruno le maire parlait d'un jour
historique c'est le cas je crois que il
ya un grand développement dans les
relations entre paris et abu dhabi et le
font normalement il est considéré parmi
les plus grands fonds dont le mode de
fonds d'investissement d'abou dhabi où
130 milliards de dollars
d'investissements dans un peu près 120
pays
donc bon il s'agit d'un partenariat très
intéressant parce que en fin de compte
le milliard qui est investi par les
imériens c'est pour des secteurs qui
sent à grand potentiel donc on parle de
l'énergie énergies renouvelables on
parle des start up et des nouvelles des
nouvelles technologies donc ça permet
pour la france d'avoir un nouveau
partenaire
mais c'est passait pas le premier
partenariat avec avec les émirats parce
qu'à des grands projets qui sont très
intéressants notamment le projet de eads
sur le développement des satellites avec
6 milliards de dollars il ya l'autre
projet également à strong ratp oui
milliards de dollars pour le
développement des métros et des tramways
à dubaï et à abou dhabi et troisièmement
aussi un autre projet qui le projet de
total avec un grand un grand partenariat
destiné à exporter 7% de l'électricité
dans le monde
concrètement on parle d'un pays comme
les émirats arabes unis une économie
émergente c'est parmi les 30 premières
économies dans le monde avec un pib qui
avoisine 400 milliards de dollars et il
ya encore plusieurs je dirais
opportunités d'affaires qui sont qui
peuvent être concrétisées par la suite
entre paris abu dhabi alors quel est
l'intérêt stratégique pour les emiratis
d'investir dans ce fonds
d'investissement français je crois qu'il
ya un très grand intérêt pour les
émirats afin de diversifier leur
économie
donc il ya tout ce qui est
l'investissement dans les secteurs
émergents comme les technologies comme
également le tourisme les banques les
secteurs de les secteurs de services et
en fin de compte sortir de cette rente
pétrolière est également il ya le
deuxième point qui est
à la question de la diversification des
partenaires on sait parfaitement que la
région du golfe elle était dépendante
pendant des décennies à l'économie
américaine a des bonnes relations avec
les états unis
maintenant surtout les émirats qui on
peut dire que ce fois abou dhabi était
vraiment pionnière là dessus sur la
question d'une ouverture vers vers
d'autres pays et surtout que les
relations avec la france ce sont des
relations qui sont très très privilégié
il faut rappeler comme quoi il ya le
projet du louvre abou dhabi aux émirats
c'est le plus grand projet culturel
porté par la france à l'étranger et à
l'université survol abou dhabi comme
étant un symbole du transfert des du
savoir faire français à à l'étranger et
ils sont négligés également que c'est un
pays qui va accueillir cette année le
l'expo dubaï en 2000 en 2020 dont il y
aura 25 millions des visiteurs est
normalement pour le pavillon français il
y aura 8 millions de visiteurs donc
c'est très intéressant pour la france
pour plus d'attractivité en termes
d'investissements et également pour la
création d'emplois est-ce que les
émirati vont demander des comptes par
rapport à l'utilisation de ce milliard
d'euros comment ça se passe je crois
qu'il s'agit d'un montage d'un montage
financier mais de toute façon d'après
les déclarations d'après également la
rencontre qui a été fait hier entre
bruno le maire et l'homme fort des
émirats le prince héritier d'abou dhabi
cheikh mohammed ben zayed al nahyane
il s'agit également d'un montage très
intéressant qui promet d'autres
investissements parce que normalement le
montrent en général ça va être de 10
milliards d'euros d'ici 2025 et il se
peut qu'il y aura encore d'autres
projets dans d'autres dans d'autres
secteurs d'activités de toute façon il
faut rappeler que ce genre
d'investissement c'est très important
pour le pays en termes d'attractivité
des investissements directs étrangers et
on est sur un partenariat gagnant
gagnant pour les nra c'est une façon de
diversifier les partenariats et de
s'ouvrir à d'autres secteurs d'activité
et pour la france c'est une façon pour
améliorer la compétitivité française et
également créer de l'emploi et de la
richesse en france donc vous de vie
c'est gagnant-gagnant pas de
contrepartie pour la france avec ce
milliard d'euros
je comprends parfaitement que dans la
scène médiatique en france on est
toujours on va dire sur cette question
de souveraineté économique on est
traître est rattachée par rapport à
cette question il ya des gens qui sont
germanophobe il y en a d'autres qui
parraine également à mergault fob il y
en a d'autres qui sont contre et les
investissements de la chine mais avec
tout ce qui se passe au niveau
économique internationale la
globalisation économique
la prolifération des nouvelles
technologies d'information et de
communication la compétitivité les
nouvelles émergences économie donc ce
sont autant de facteurs qui participent
à ce genre de partenariat et qui laisse
une grande place pour le commerce
international et pour des synergies
entre différents pays surtout qu' il
faut rappeler que l'aspect politique ici
il est très important parce que les
émirats sont des vrais partenaires avec
des grands partenaires pour la france il
ya une vision commune par rapport à tout
ce qui se passe dans le moyen-orient en
libye en l'occurrence dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et il faut rappeler
aussi qu'il ya une base militaire
française dans la région de djofra à 30
km d'abou dhabi avec une présence de 700
soldats français
merci beaucoup younès vais le faire
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle